à écouter cet appel du président russe
se bladimir poutine cet acte de
communication
oui si vous voyez que des gens veulent
tirer volontairement
qui plus est sans gagner d'argent aider
ceux qui vivent dans le donbass
alors il faut aller à leur rencontre
et les aider à rejoindre la zone de
combat
des ingénieurs vadimir poutine ordonne
l'envoi de combattants volontaires que
recouvre cette proposition alors
volontaires mercenaires en tout cas le
ministre de la défense russe a précisé
même que seize mille combattants étaient
prêts à aider les forces russes venant
essentiellement du moyen-orient de syrie
ou encore de libye des combattants qui
ont combattu avec des mini siens des
miliciens russe je pense notamment au
groupe wagner sa corrobore finalement
des informations aussi que la presse
britannique et américaine avait donné
déjà depuis depuis deux semaines alors
pourquoi cet appel ou cette acceptation
de volontaires d'une part vous rappelez
peut-être hier enfin disons que la
question des soldats est extrêmement
importante hier pour la première fois le
kremlin a reconnu qu'il y avait des
jeunes conscrits dans les forces armés
qui avaient été envoyés en ukraine ce
qui avait été totalement nié jusqu'à
maintenant et d'ailleurs c'est un
problème parce que vladimir poutine a
dit c'est une erreur ce qui est enfin si
ça a été fait il faut que des
gouverneurs qui sont responsables de ça
soit sanctionné c'est une question
extrêmement sensible parce que
officiellement les russes ne font pas la
guerre ils ont une opération spéciale
avec des soldats spécialisés et
professionnelles et professionnels et on
sait que le retour enfin certains jeunes
soldats sont prêts sont sont maintenant
prisonniers des ukrainiens d'autres ont
été tuées et en ukraine en russie pardon
là une des associations qui est très
puissante qui peut encore déstabiliser
pas mal le pouvoir c'est l'association
des mères de soldats c'est une
association qui avait été fondée en 1989
qui réclamaient des informations sur le
corps sur les soldats jeunes conscrits
qui combattaient en afghanistan ensuite
en tchétchénie et donc c'est un
véritable voilà voilà voilà l'enjeu donc
c'est volontaire ou mercenaires sont des
gens plus aguerris plus expérimenté et
il pourrait effectivement venir aider
les troupes russes dont on dit qu elle l
avance certes mais plus lentement que
prévu l'ukraine a annoncé à la création
d'une légion d'étrangers volontaire
intégré à ses forces armées quelles sont
les personnes qui répondent à cet appel
alors oui effectivement au début du
conflit le président et lens qui a fait
appel à des volontaires étrangers ils
seraient 20000 devenons de 52 pays
différent d'après le ministre des
affaires étrangères ukrainien ils
viennent des états unis d'europe des
pays voisins comme la géorgie ou encore
des opposants biélorusses mais aussi
plus étonnant des coréens des japonais
et même des thaïlandais ils ont des
profils et des expériences militaires
extrêmement varié ça peut être des
anciens militaires des étudiants ou
encore des aventuriers auront des
motivations souvent politiques ayant
l'impression de se battre pour la
liberté contre l'oppression russe ça
fait référence aussi ses combattants à
des combats aux brigades internationales
tout simplement dans le conflit dans la
guerre civile espagnole
absolument mais certains sont aussi
fasciné tout simplement par le
patriotisme et l'ultra l'ultra droite en
tout cas ce ne sont pas des mercenaires
parce que quand ces volontaires arrivent
et il y a eu plusieurs reportages et
d'ailleurs s'il n'est pas bien on a
rencontré aussi sont en principe intégré
officiellement dans l'armée ukrainienne
et voilà donc pour l'instant en tout cas
on sait enfin officiellement d'après les
ukrainiens ils sont vingt mille a
vérifié évidemment alors sur le terrain
la question des civils et des réfugiés
de la dîmière poutine propose des
corridors humanitaires qui devait
s'ouvrir aujourd'hui mais vers la russie
est pas vers le cren ouvert vers
l'europe c'est un plan machiavélique
qu'il poursuit c'est très sûr pour enfin
c'est très surprenant c'est à dire
depuis maintenant plusieurs jours les
corridors qui sont négociés
par les russes se sont se dirige vers la
russie ce qui est absolument contre agde
la biélorussie ou la biélorussie alors
comment comment l'expliquez est ce que
c'est une façon de prendre la population
ukrainienne en otage celle qui veut fuir
est ce que c'est une façon aussi de
démoraliser la population de démoraliser
la résistance autre possibilité ce qui
est intéressant en tout cas c'est que ça
s'inscrit dans le narratif russe qui est
de dire nous sommes allés en ukraine
pour une opération spéciale pour libérer
les populations de leurs joues soi
disant nous sommes là pour les
accueillir et pour les protéger de cette
jeunesse voilà de cette engeance nazis
donc ça s'inscrit tout à fait dans leur
âme narratif russe merci beaucoup
virginie hertz pour votre